هذه المروحيه الهجوميه الاوكرانيه اقلعت
من قاعده سريه شرق البلاد بمهمه محفوفه
بالمخاطر تحلق على ارتفاع منخفض متجهه الى
باخم لاستهداف رتل عسكري ومواقع روسيه هذه
الصور التقطتها وكاله فانس برس من داخل
المروحيه حيث يوجد الطيار الاوكراني بيترو
الذي قبل بالادلاء بشهادته من دون الكشف
عن
هويته الهدف هو التحليق على ارتفاع منخفض
قدر الامكان وعدم الظهور على النظام
الرادار الروسي بحيث لا يعرفون اي شيء حتى
اللحظه الاخيره وهذا يمنعهم من التواصل مع
بعضهم البعض لكي لا يتمكنوا من تحذير
بعضهم من وجود مروحيه العدو سوف يروننا في
النهايه على اي حال يجب ان لا نمنحهم
الوقت للرد هذه المروحيات القتاليه مجهزه
بالصواريخ 15 على الجانب الايمن و1 على
اليسار تحديد الهدف يتم قبل وقت قصير من
الانطلاق امر ضروري لنجاح مهمه بترو في
يومه ال منذ
تجنيده بمجرد تشغيل المحرك يختفي الخوف
لاننا تدربنا على ذلك لدي ثقه في نفسي وفي
طقمي لذلك ابدا الرحله من دون خوف يجب
الاعتماد فقط على مهاراتك وما تعلمته من
المقرر ان تستغرق الرحله 30 دقيقه ذهابا
وايابا على ارتفاع يبلغ اقصاه 180 مترا
على بعد 6 كيلومترات من الهدف تطلق الصو
ثم على ارتفاع منخفض ايضا تحلق المروحيه
وتعود على الفور الى قاعدتها العسكريه
تاركه خلفها طائره بدون طيار لتتحقق من
اصابه
الهدف الجزء الاصعب هو الاستعداد للمهمه
واتخاذ القرار بشان كيفيه التصرف اثناء
الرحله في اي اتجاه ستتحرك نحو الهدف
وستطلق النار لانك لا تعرف تضاريس الموقع
قبل الرحله نفسها لذا لا يمكن التاكد من
ان كل شيء سيسير على ما
مهمه برو انتهت بنجاح وتم تدمير جميع
الاهداف في اوكرانيا يتناقل رواد مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي صور المروحيات القتاليه
الاوكرانيه بكثافه هنا الطيارون ابطال لكن
منذ بدء الحرب قتل حوالي 30 منهم خلال
مهمه قتاليه